[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire
c'est le cres octobre cette fois qui a
tout déclenché des collégiens et des
lycéennes se sont vu refuser l'accès à
leur établissement scolaire
parce qu'elle arborait un au cours et
moules en dévoilant le nombril comme
emportait les spice girls et britney
spears dans les années 90 c'est pourquoi
laurent ont refusé l'entrée c'est parce
que c'était indécent la réponse ne s'est
pas fait attendre un appel était lancé
pour le 14 septembre à manifester et
tous et toutes habillées de bagnères en
descente en croque top en jupe avec du
maquillage etc etc
là dessus le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanc coeur a
déclaré qu'il fallait aller à l'école
habillée de façon républicaine
elisabeth morano le ministre la ministre
déléguée à l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes et les hommes lui a répondu
qu'en france chacun est libre de
s'habiller comme il veut et que les
femmes ont mis des siècles à pouvoir
s'affranchir des codes vestimentaires et
que cette liberté chèrement conquise n'a
pas de prix sauf que marianne
l'hebdomadaire a publié un sondage selon
lequel 55% des français voudrait
interdire le crop top aux lycéennes et
66% le fait de ne pas porter de soutien
gorge et même 62 % voudraient interdire
les décolletés plongeants visiblement le
corps des femmes reste un objet de
polémique en ce début de 21ème siècle
alors pour en débattre nous avons invité
peggy sastre elle est docteur en
philosophie des sciences le c'est
l'auteur de la domination masculine
n'existe pas de comment l'amour
emprisonne les femmes
votre dernier essai peggy sastre c'est
la haine orpheline nous y avons consacré
tout un numéro d' interdit d'interdire
sa sortie chez anne carrière en mai
dernier
alors comment analysez-vous ce moment
très particulier où l'on a dit où tout
le monde s'est mis à dire aux jeunes
filles comment il fallait qu'elle
s'habille pour aller à l'école
ben en fait je pense pas qu'il soit si
particulier que ça dans le sens où moi
je me rappelle que je suis pas non plus
j'ai pas non plus en temps mais je la
vois je vais avoir 40 et je me rappelle
que quand j'étais au collège il y avait
déjà des ce genre de polémique on a eu
il y avait au début des années 2000 je
crois y avait eu une polémique autour de
ségolène royal qui avait dit qu'il
fallait interdire
le string qui dépasse les pantalons
taille basse toujours des trucs donc en
fait ce qu'on remarque c'est que les
modes les mots de passe mais c'est
toujours en gros c'est toujours le même
comme venir c'est toujours à la fois les
mêmes traits que les jeunes femmes les
jeunes filles mettent en valeur et c'est
toujours c'est ce sur quoi on lire sur
cette source sûre sur ces mêmes traits
que l'ailé comme on dire les crispations
les crispations se fixe donc
effectivement c'est la poitrine c'est la
finesse détails de la taille c'est la
générosité des hanches
voilà donc voilà c'est en gros voilà en
résumé ce que je voulais dire c'est que
c'est pas si c'est passé pas si c'est
pas si particulier de ça et c'est ce et
c'est justement très intéressant et très
parlants que ce soit toujours les mêmes
les mêmes voilà l'ailé même genre de
polémique qui reviennent à intervalles
réguliers
camille il extrait vous êtes étudiante
en communication politique et vous êtes
membre de collage féminicide paris c'est
un mouvement féministe de collage de rue
qui a un peu plus d'un an maintenant et
qui affiche pendant la nuit dans la
capitale des slogans contre les
violences dont les femmes sont victimes
comment vous analysé ce moment vous oui
tout à fait je sais pas si document on
dénonce les violences subies par les
femmes et les minorités de genre et je
pense que le débat tel qu'il a été conçu
jusqu'à maintenant après ce qui était
détournée de son centre principal on
parle de la liberté de s'habiller des
femmes en réalité ici on parle d'enfants
du coup on doit parler aussi de
pédocriminalité de normalisation de la
pédocriminalité du regard des adultes
sur des corps d'enfants qu'ils aient
sexualise et la sexualisation aussi des
relations entre enfants on prépare aussi
c'est ses enfants à vivre toute leur vie
des violences tout rappel il ya une
femme sur cinq qui subira des violences
sexuelles lors de sa vie au travail et
donc on prépare ces enfants-là à subir
toute leur vie ces violences là et on
excuse le regard et de crinière de là
société ce qui n'est absolument pas ce
gars fier de chaque vous vous êtes
écrivain et éditrice vous êtes l'auteur
de les femmes s'emmerde au lit le
désirent à l'épreuve du féminisme et de
la pornographie
vous êtes l'auteur de ma fille conseil
au maire d'ado c'était chez plon et mais
aussi de l'encyclo des filles que vous
avez publié chaque année de 2002 à 2010
est alors vous voulez vous l'analysez
comment ce boom ce moment à moi je pense
qu'il est quand même assez particulier
je sais pas combien de temps il va durer
mais il est évidemment dans le sillage
de 2,2 ce qui a commencé la deuxième
vague dans les années 70 de l'art et de
super révolution sexuelle
les femmes en temps de reprendre le
contrôle de leur corps mais en même
temps elles veulent plaire ce qui est
extrêmement sain c'est un désir un désir
c'est un désir naturel et il ya des
excès moi je pense que c'est plutôt très
bien ce qui est en train de se passer
parce que ça met sur la table plein de
choses parce qu'il ya beaucoup de double
injonction c'est à dire que que les
femmes décident de comment elles veulent
présenter leur corps je trouve ça plutôt
très bien
il faut tenir compte du fait que
effectivement on s'adresse à des petites
filles et que ou même des adolescentes
et que on se rend pas forcément compte
de to 2 to de tous les enjeux qui lie à
derrière un crop octobre un regard etc
et puis il y a il est vrai et ça sera
bien de s'en débarrasser un regard quand
même patriarcale sur le corps des femmes
et qui suscite évidemment aujourd'hui le
le débat et et dont beaucoup de femmes
heureusement souhaite se débarrasser
médias la zone où vous êtes journaliste
fondatrice de ce pick up channel vous
animez le nadia l'edge unis chaud alors
vous vous voyez ça comment nadia et bien
alors moi ça me fait penser à la lutte
contre le séparatisme
on lutte contre le séparatisme pour
restaurer un ordre républicain et
visiblement ça doit aussi passer par
l'instauration d'une d'une tenue
républicaine est donc finalement le
choix vestimentaire des femmes redevient
en fait ma l'objet d'un débat national
alors c'est vrai qu'on avait l'habitude
de débattre du couvre chef
les femmes des françaises musulmanes là
c'est un peu nouveau parle maintenant
des crocs top détenus jugés moulante et
on peut aussi noter c'est quand même ce
paradoxe c'est qu'on recourt à ce
qualificatif de républicains pour à la
fois proscrire détenus qui seraient très
trop couvrante comme l'egypte par
exemple et proscrire également détenus
qui ne le serait pas assez et au fond
finalement effectivement c'est toujours
la libre disposition dans la femme fin
la femme le droit de la femme de
disposer de son corps comme à l'entente
qui est questionnée mais ça ne doit pas
pour autant occulter aussi un autre
problème celui de l'hypersexualisation
croissante et inquiétant des jeunes
filles elle rogne et on vient en aide ou
nieront oui je vais y arriver le 10
rencontres est tombé à essayer de
traiter tous ces sujets mais commençons
par le par le début on dirait que
dénudés des parties de son corps quand
on est une femme ou une jeune femme
ça semble poser problème alors d'après
ce que disait peggy sastre ça a toujours
posé problème mais on peut imaginer que
dans les années 2020 maintenant voilà
c'était passé on avait accepté tout ça
visiblement pas alors pourquoi ça
continue de poser problème
peggy babin si vous voulez mon avis
c'est parce que ce sont des caractères
sexuels secondaires qui sont montrés et
donc pour tous que comment dire ces
caractères sexuels secondaires ont été
façonnés par l'évolution même pour avoir
un but pour imputer reproductif et donc
celui de reproductif et qu'il est il
excite le désir sexuel en majorité en
moyenne en moyenne des mâles des mains
d'emma l'humain
donc ça c'est très intéressant parce que
justement c'est sonia faire ça qui
parlait de double injonction mais c'est
moi danser double injonction en fait je
vois un déni et une ignorance en fait de
2 2 voilà deux le blog de la biologie
des bases des bases biologiques des
comportements et voilà il ne pas ne pas
comment ils ne pas avoir conscience de
ça en fait ça ça mais les femmes ça mais
les femmes dans un dans une position de
en fait d'infériorité pour comment ils
ont elles sont elles n'ont pas davantage
parce qu'elles ne savent pas en fait
elles ne savent pas le pouvoir qu'elles
peuvent avoir sur sur les hommes et
notamment et notamment les les geler les
jeunes hommes et comme et comme on leur
explique dans une part du film dans dans
une partie du féminisme qui est
aujourd'hui tiré leur taux ducks
dominante tout ce qu'on veut que non non
c'est pas du tout naturel et attention
il faut pas il faut pas parler vélo y
fixer des rats mais justement ça laisse
aller mais dans sa salle et met dans une
position où allah on est dans la double
injonction et on est justement dans un
dans une situation qui pose problème et
qui peut justement ouvrir sur des
violences etc
et moi je suis totalement comment dire
je suis totalement dans la droite ligne
de ce que disait marc écurie n'a rien ay
arena n'a rien à craindre tout est à
comprendre jeu est en tout cas cessé
c'est l'objet de deux de mes travaux que
quand on comprend voilà quand on compte
pas qu'on comprend la biologie et la
libération la libération féminine et
féministe est d'autant plus efficiente
kla l'extrait pack leur pardon camille
l'extrait que vous en pensez quoi
moi je fais partie des féministes qui ne
sont pas très attaché à la biologie même
le moins du monde et je pense que c'est
surtout les constructions sociales et
les construit qu'il faut réussir à
comprendre qu'il faut creuser comprendre
pourquoi est ce que on a sexualisé ces
corps là pourquoi est-ce que
effectivement les caractéristiques
sexuels secondaires comme des saints
qui ne sont pas en fait des organes
génitaux parce qu'il paraît évident sont
autant planter du doigt je pense que
c'est aussi là qu'il faut interroger
notre regard est aussi notre laxisme
il se trouve que en france il ya moins
d'un pour cent des violeurs qui sont
condamnées parce que justement il ya
cette pépite gueule ou on met une part
de responsabilité sur le corps des
femmes par exemple dans les viols et
donc cette mentalité de dire couvrez ce
sein que je ne saurais voir
un peu comme dans tartuffe qu'on a
aujourd'hui avec le ministre de
l'éducation
c'est une mentalité qui après excuses
le violeur si la personne avait un
proctologue si la personne avait un
décolleté
dans ce cas là elle la chercher et elle
n'avait qu'à pas se montrer encore une
fois ici on parle de corps d'enfants en
plus qu'ils n'ont pas à être sexualisé
c'est pas parce qu'on a des seins et on
est une enfant on à être sexualisé c'est
absolument indécent il ya cette
complaisance française envers la
pédocriminalité les noix bien autant
dans les médias que dans le monde du
cinéma par exemple dernièrement et en
fait il ya un holà à mettre un stop
non il n'est pas normal de voir les
seins comme quelque chose de sexuel
on doit libérer en fait cette poitrine
là et c'est essentiel en fait comme on
doit libérer de manière générale les
femmes et leur donner le droit de
s'habiller comme elle elle souhaite à
tout instant aucune lieu parce que on
est en train d' excuses et encore une
fois les comportements toxiques des
hommes
on devrait éduquer les hommes plutôt
qu'en permanence essayé d'expliquer aux
femmes comment elles devraient
s'habiller soit retiré leurs droits
soient au pétrole remonter leurs
tee-shirts et indécent c'est ça la
véritable un des plus calmes et
l'extrait éduquer moi un peu c'était
jusqu'à quel âge un enfant pour qu'on
soit parcours sache tous
justement c'est là c'est intéressant
c'est que la loi française qui a été
fait en 2018 a refusé de mettre un
minimum d'âge pour le consentement c'est
à dire qu'aujourd'hui
oui oui c'est ce que je voulais vous
attendre d'y réaliser c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui en france une personne
qui a 11 ans - peut être jugé comme
consentantes
lorsqu'un actes sexuels avec une
personne adulte et donc c'est là où pour
moi encore une fois il ya ce contexte de
2,2 d'aveuglément face à la
pédocriminalité en france ou en fait
justement on ne qualifie pas ce qui est
être un une enfant elle qualifie pas à
quel moment il y à a vu et on permet en
fait à sa pédocriminalité d'avoir un
terreau jusque dans nos propres lois
il n'y a pas de véritable lutte contre
la pédocriminalité et le fait que le
ministre de l'enseignement ose dire
qu'il faut une tenue républicaine plutôt
que de réprimander tous ces professeurs
cpe etc qui porte un regard
pédocriminels sur des enfants
c'est la véritable indécence en effet
donc il n'y a pas de majorité donc pas
non plus de minorités sexuelles en
france et ça a été confirmé en 2018
sachant que ça n'existait pas déjà avant
donc ce soit bien clair
il n'ya pas battant on peut quand même
avoir une idée de ce que c'est qu'un
enfant sonia psirt chaque du côté du
côté de la construction
si on a un décolleté est ce que on joue
avec avec des caractères sexuels
secondaires que la biologie nous à nous
a fourni ou est ce que on joue avec des
constructions que la société nous a
rempilé sur chacun d'entre vous eh ben
je vais vous embêter mais les deux c'est
à dire que là où je suis d'accord avec
camille c'est que c'est les femmes ont
toujours été historiquement toujours
coupable d désire qu'elle suscite et les
hommes jamais responsables de ce qu'ils
éprouvent donc ça serait bien de changer
ça mais après la question qu'il faudrait
poser à camille
c'est pour l'instant les seins ils ont
le statut des mollets au 18e on va dire
c'est à dire que pour l'instant les
montrer c'est de la sexualité est ce que
vous souhaiteriez c'est une vraie
question ouverte
moi je mets ces personnages je dis pas
que j'ai raison c'est à dire que quant à
moi j'ai envie que mes seins ça reste
quelque chose que je ne je ne montre pas
à tout le monde pour moi j'ai envie que
ça reste de la sexualité et on pourrait
très bien imaginer et je suis très
frappé des jeunes filles qui de plus en
plus ne porte pas de soutien-gorge et
veulent en quelque sorte banaliser les
saints comme les bras comme les mollets
aujourd'hui et on peut imaginer une
société où les femmes se se baladeront
ou pas est-ce que ça sera possible une
société où les femmes se baladeront
seins nus et plus personne n'y fera ni
fera attention comme alors peut-être pas
dans la rue mais disons quand on fait
son jardin
ed seins nus comme les hommes sont torse
nu donc ça c'est là dessus il ya quelque
chose de culturel
après là où je suis d'accord avec peggy
c'est que et surtout quand on parle des
ados c'est qu'il ya quelque chose
d'hormones halles qui se passe et il ya
le fait de regarder de découvrir le
désir le désir du corps de l'autre les
garçons sont extrêmement il regarde
soudain les corps des filles avaient
avec concupiscence qui n'abuse c'est une
découverte pour eux
j'ajouterai aussi et c'est très
important que les jeunes filles si on
leur dit pas que elles peuvent susciter
justement le désir elles changent
parfois en six mois c'est à dire que
elle met un petit leggins et une
brassière et ça passera ça sera ça sera
voilà anodin et puis six mois plus tard
elle explose parce qu'elles ont des
formes et tout à coup elles vont plus du
tout susciter les mêmes regards alors je
suis d'accord qu'il faut que les hommes
apprennent peut-être plus de plus en
plus à respecter les femmes mais l on
pourra sans doute pas tout de suite en
tout cas et c'est sans doute pas bien
d'empêcher se regardent désire donc ça
il faut il faut instruire aussi les
jeunes filles voilà pour les protéger et
les instruire le problème c'est que
cette interdiction du crop top qui
voudraient les protéger elle est perçue
comme une volonté de dominer encore une
fois de 2,2 mètres une mainmise si je
peux dire sur le sur le corps des femmes
c'est ça qui est très complice compliqué
mais à chaque fois on parle d'instruire
les jeunes filles
est ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression
que les jeunes filles d'aujourd'hui en
savent deux fois plus que leur mère au
même âge dix fois plus que leur
grand-mère au même âge elles en ont sans
doute aussi fait beaucoup plus mais ça à
la limite on n'en sait rien mais en tout
cas ils en savent plus arrêtons
d'essayer de les instruire
elles en savent beaucoup plus que jean
michel blanquer sa part une évidence
juste attention parce que oui elles sont
très instruite
mais quand à ressentir ce qui se passe
dans son corps c'est encore autre chose
et puis être instruit par par internet
par tout ce qui se passe les blogs
féministes etc
c'est très bien mais après il ya aussi
ce qu'elles vivent ce qu'elle rencontre
on n'est pas forcément armé quand on a
11 12 ans effectivement pour pour
affronter certain regard qu'on
n'imaginerait pas déclenchée parce qu'on
n'est pas prête pour ça parce qu'on on
n'a pas encore intériorisé ça donc tout
ça complexifie beaucoup la situation
elles ont 14 15 ans quand même plus
souvent que 11 12 ans quand elle mort du
maître des crop top non la discussion
d'accord il ya discussion on trouve des
strings taille 6 ans
c'est absolument scandaleux on trouve
des chaussures à talons des dès l'âge de
3 ans il ya aussi toute une toute une
comment dire une force du capitalisme il
faut quand même le dire pour vendre des
produits qui font rêver c'est à dire que
là aussi il ya une confusion les petites
filles essayez les talons de leurs
mamans et d'ailleurs les petits garçons
aussi et ça faisait ça faisait partie
d'un jeu c'est on dirait qu'on serait
est alors qu'aujourd'hui on peut les
acheter et aller à l'école avec et
sortir avec et ça change complètement la
donne on n'est plus dans un jeu à la
télé
oui enfin je rejoins ce qui vient d'être
dit c'est que le problème c'est qu'une
fois de plus on incrimine le corps des
femmes
hélas aujourd'hui de jeunes mineurs
effectivement qui doivent être oui
instruite et du quai alors vous parliez
de cette instruction de ces jeunes
filles qui peut-être en savent beaucoup
plus que monsieur blanc caire marc après
quelles sont leurs sources d'information
aujourd'hui on a une génération qui est
un peu la génération née dans la
pornographie et alors c'est pas moi qui
le dit c'est des sociologues et
notamment des sociologues canadien qui
alertent justement sur cette hyper
sexualisation croissante et qui font
remarquer qu'aujourd'hui la pornographie
dicte des normes et vient bouleverser
profondément en fait la culture donc
c'est justement précisément le rôle de
l'école est d'instruire ces jeunes
filles justement sur peut-être des
risques d'être réduite finalement
finalement a alors à tour à être un
objet d'être condamné à être un objet de
séduction parce qu'aujourd'hui la femme
et la fille pour plaire dans cette
société
eh bien on leur dit que ça passe par le
sexe ce qui a aussi quand même assez
problématique
il y avait autre chose que je voulais
dire
et mince ça m'a complètement c'est que
vous il ya aussi cette duplication bien
évidemment qui doit l'être des parcs de
l'éducation des jeunes filles mais
l'éducation des jeunes hommes
effectivement l'homme n'est absolument
pas inquiété et c'est ça qui est juste
ahurissant fait finalement 2 dans ce
sondage on ne questionne pas sa
responsabilité on ne questionne pas son
regard concupiscent le fait qu'ils
puissent aussi approché le sexe opposé
sans être dominée par une forme d'anneau
animalité et donc oui voilà il faut
responsabiliser les deux sexes et c'est
pour ça que ce sondage pose problème
c'est qu'il est il est sexiste
en fait on n'aurait pas eu l'idée de
dicter une certaine tenue aux hommes
même si dans d'autres espaces comme
notamment le travail
oui on réglemente la tenue il ya des
correcte des détenus qui sont kiki dont
les usages en tout cas dans certaines
entreprises
c'est réglementé et un règlement natal
on connaît tous la jurisprudence du port
du bermuda par exemple un licenciement
avaient été validés parce qu'un homme
était venu en bermuda une femme avaient
été licenciés aussi parce qu'elle
portait un chemisier et qu'on voyait
aussi sa poitrine donc ont finalement
dans différents espaces on réglemente
les tenues le problème c'est qu'entre le
monde surtout la tenue la femme alors
justement quand il ya eu les quand tu es
à 52,2 d'établissement voulu interdire
les crocs top les garçons ont pris le
parti des filles d'ailleurs dans l'appel
à manifester le 14 septembre ça
s'adressait aussi bien aux garçons
qu'aux filles on est justement un moment
où la jeune génération des garçons elle
aussi veut être sexy et les garçons ont
tendance aussi à découvrir des parties
de leur corps ce que ne faisait pas les
garçons dans les générations précédentes
ils doivent être d'ailleurs assez déçu
qu'on ne les assimile pas eux aussi à
des tenues sexy ou trop sexy c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être un peu d eau
c'est vrai que un garçon au short
personnes il faut car proche une fille
en mini jupe ou une fille en short
d'ailleurs on pourrait commencer à la
regarder de travers
là aussi comment vous expliquez ça paie
10 sastre toujours à peu près d'être
toujours à peu près par là même pas par
là même la même base que saint siège
rappeler qu'il ya un certain fossé une
fausse d'économie et de dire que soit
c'est la biologie soit sociale
culturelle et les deux les deux font
système mais le fait est que la culture
ne parle pas de comment dire le la
culture n'est pas arbitraire et part et
par et parle d'une base biologique n'est
pas c'est pas un hasard pour pourquoi
donc dans toutes ses dents toutes les
cultures dans toutes les cultures du
monde c'est pas c'est pas le coude qui
est sexuelle ce n'est pas le nez c'est
ce genre de choses ce sont ce sont
toujours les mêmes traits ce sont
toujours les à-peu-près en mois en
moyenne les mêmes traits sur lequel
comme darty sont considérés justement
com dcom comme des traits comme des
traits sexuelle et pour reprendre le ce
que ce que ce que disait camus quand
elle dit les seins c'est pas des organes
sexuels mais mais mais justement tête
ccc la définition d'un caractères
sexuels secondaires 7,7 en fait c'est un
caractère sexuel coin d'herbe c est un
trait qui n'est pas directement comme on
le dit rien qui n'est pas directement un
outil de leur production donc en fait et
tout ce qui n'est en fait c'est tout ce
qui n'est pas quand mais c'est tout ce
qui est sexuel tout en n'étant pas les
organes et les organes génitaux donc
dont les saints dont les seins pour les
femmes la finesse et la finesse de la
taille par rapport par rapport aux
hanches etc
et voilà et c'est justement ce serait
c'est très amusant ce que vous ce que
vous disiez sur comment est-ce que ça
fait quoi quand comment est-ce que ça se
fait que pendant quand un garçon se met
en short c'est pas la même ce n'était
pas la même réaction moyenne et général
qu'elle continue 6ème et en charge
justement c'est que l'évolution n'a pas
comment dire les brin'chieux l'évolution
n'a pas agi sur les mêmes sur le sur les
mêmes éléments entre ce sont les mâles
et les femelles mais que ça sauf que
perçoit les humains ou d'autres buts
mammifères ou même d'autres espèces
d'espèces animales
papa m'a pas mammifères et ça et ça
c'est vraiment comment dire et c'est
toujours très compliqué pour moi
d'arriver dans ce genre de des dons ce
genre de débat parce qu'il ya quand
monia
il ya vraiment une base il y avait quand
même encore il comme dernièrement une
base presque documentaire qui en fait
qu'il n'ait paquin et qui n'est pas
connu et moi je peux pas arriver avec
avec mes petits bras may et bah voilà ce
que vous connaissez la sélection
sexuelle scocco darwin ben en fait c'est
cette base là n'est pas connue donc
c'est très compliqué à c'est très
compliqué d'avoir comme mounir d'avoir
même d'être entendu parce que c'est
quelque chose qui n'est kiné qui n'est
vraiment pas cne et pour le regrette et
qui n'est pas voilà a passe est passé
dans la culture comme comme d'autres
comme d'autres notions comme notre
notion scientifique et son lot ils sont
tout au tout aussi fondamental pour
notre compréhension de la vie courante
quoi donc quoi qu'il arrive
malheureusement pour les garçons qui
voudraient faire carrière dans ce
domaine
s'il commence à se déshabiller ça ne
soulèvera pas la république ça ne fera
jamais le même effet que si c'est une
femme qui le fait j'ai bien résumé la
jamais jaoui jeu jamais j'en sais rien
mais tant que voilà donc tant que nous
restons attend que tout reste ont eu une
espèce sexuée et que la reproduction se
fait par par la fusion des des gamètes
mâles et des gamètes femelles oui on
peut considérer que quand mia en
tendance en moyenne en général ça ça
suscitera beaucoup moins de beaucoup
moins de problème est rien comme on le
sait aussi qu est magique avec avec avec
la porte l'évolution heure c'est qu'en
fait rien n'est rien et rien n'est fixé
rien n'est déterminé et que si voilà si
si si l'environnement change peut-être
que les choses vont changer on peut tout
imaginer mais dans les voilà dans les
dents dans l'état actuel des choses que
ça change court terme on fait une pause
on va voir si ça change quelque chose on
se retrouve juste après pour continuer
ce débat
[Musique]
le secteur de l'immobilier a n'a pas été
épargnés par les mesures sanitaires
d'urgence mis en place par le
gouvernement les banques aujourd'hui
donc on sait qu'elles vont un peu coupé
les robinets et si elle coupe les
robinets ça va être un petit peu plus
compliqué pour l'immobilier l'immobilier
haut de gamme était la valeur refuge par
excellence celle qu'un qui a plus de 75
ans a priori l'achète pas un appartement
il le vent et comme il aura pas beaucoup
de retraite
il est assez probable qu'ils soient
obligés de vendre son actif pour
continuer à vivre
il ya un vieillissement de la population
qui fait que vous allez avoir une baisse
des prix dit aujourd'hui que c'est la
revanche des campagnes contre les villes
parce que les villes souffrent
globalement tout le marché comme dit
olivier de ne pas devenir plus
raisonnable
les acquéreurs vont être plus sélectifs
la france fait partie de ces pays qui
ont mal géré cette crise je crois qu'on
ne pouvait pas échapper au confinement à
partir du moment où on n'avait pas su
anticiper cette crise et la préparer il
ya un point d'interrogation pour
l'opinion c'est qu'on a beaucoup
emprunté je crois qu'on pouvait pas
faire autrement
l'échec sanitaire entraîne l'échec
économique
c'est sans doute la dernière fois que la
france peut emprunter 20 à 30% de son
pipe pour essayer pas tellement de
relancer son économie mais vraiment de
reconstruire un modèle est cette fois ci
nous n'avons plus droit à l'erreur
vous nous expliquer qu effectivement le
réveil va être compliqué il va être
douloureux il ya eu un moment de très
grand relâchement et nous sommes en
train de payer ce moment de très grand
relâchement
donc c'est bien parce qu'on a échoué
dans la gestion de l'épidémie
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train d'échouer
dans la relance
[Musique]
on continue ce débat avec peggy sastre
qui est docteur en philosophie des
sciences avec camille l'extrait qui est
membre du mouvement féministe collage
féminicide paris avec sonia faire de
chaque qui est écrivain et nadia les
deux uniques et journalistes donc pour
résumer ce que disait peggy sastre
en gros les sexes sont différents un
homme et une femme c'est pas la même
chose
et forcément ça provoque des réactions
différentes
camille l'extrême évident que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord non mais peut-être
que je le dirai avec moins de
condescendance
le set est aussi une construction
sociale en réalité ailleurs il ya certes
les gamètes
il ya les organes génitaux il ya tout un
tas de facteurs qui déterminent ce
qu'est le sexe et les hormones aussi qui
vont intervenir dans la manière dont on
va définir le sexe mais il faut savoir
que la manière dont on définit le sexe
en france en 2020
c'est une construction sociale on
observe de manière externe
comment ça se passe et en détermine un
sexe en réalité y aurait bien un critère
on peut aussi parler de genre qu'il a
pour le coup peut-être aussi une
construction sociale mais où chaque
personne va déterminer son genre et je
pense que c'est un discours qui est
assez dangereux en fait d'expliquer tout
tout ce sexisme en fait toutes les
pulsions soi-disant masculine par le
sexe aux réalités biologiquement parlant
ya rien qui explique ça et d'ailleurs
c'est un discours qui oublie totalement
le fait que tout le monde n'est pas
hétérosexuels là depuis le début de
l'émission de l'impression que tous les
adolescents de la planète entière sont
hétérosexuels ce n'est pas vrai comment
ça se fait que par exemple une
adolescente lesbiennes ne va pas avoir
la même réaction face à un corps d'une
autre adolescente dénudées tout
simplement parce que ça vient aussi de
la construction et du regard qu'on
m'autorise aux hommes a porté sur sur
les femmes c'est ça qui est extrêmement
important on parlait un peu plus tôt la
pornographie et du rôle que ça joue dans
les représentations et dans l'éducation
je pense qu'effectivement il ya un rôle
à jouer de l'école et le souci c'est pas
tellement pour moi la pornographie en
tant que tel c'est que les jeunes ont
comme seul moyen d'éducation la
pornographie parce qu'il n'ya pas
d'éducation sexuelle à l'école ou très
peu et qu'en plus elle est hétéro centre
est et six centres et donc c'est des
problèmes on n'apprend pas véritablement
aux jeunes les clés de compréhension de
leur sexualité et de leur fonctionnement
donc le souci c'est pas la pornographie
c'est qu'ils rien en face
et donc culpabiliser les personnes qui
portent un croc top c'est en aucun cas
une éducation pour moi c'est une
culpabilisation supplémentaire et c'est
une excuse donné aux hommes pour leurs
regards et leurs pulsions - l'éducation
elle doit être surtout du côté des
hommes on appelle tout temps les femmes
à se protéger à être vigilante à faire
attention mais on dit jamais aux hommes
mais ne viole pas et en fait c'est aussi
simple que ça quelque part c'est qu' il
faut une fin de cette impunité
il faut une fin de cette logique que
nous serions responsables des agressions
que nous subissons et parce que c'est
tout simplement pas normal s'il ya
seulement 1% des violeurs qui sont
condamnés en france aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'on est purement dans cette
logique là que quelque part quand on
subit un violent on a forcément une part
de responsabilité c'est soit notre tenue
soit qu'on était à un endroit on ne
devrait pas être ce qu'on avait pris de
l'alcool ou des substances qu'on
n'aurait pas dû prendre et donc on va
pour les femmes
dire que le consentement passe partout
ces critères-là alors que pour un homme
le consentement passe par un oui
simplement
donc le fait qu'ils aient un peu ce
double traitement qu on exige des femmes
une exemplarité
et justement autant au niveau de la
tenue où il faut être dans un entre deux
c'est pas normal et c'est à cause du
regard masculin qu'on n'est dupe a entre
autre combat imposé sa au corps des
femmes si un homme peut porter un short
est pas une femme
c'est pas parce qu'il ya une différence
biologique c'est tout simplement parce
qu'on a sexualisé les gens des femmes
qui peuvent être totalement similaire
des jambes des hommes dans les
caractéristiques sexuels secondaires
il ya les poils aussi par exemple les
femmes auront ça fait partie des
caractéristiques sexuels secondaires
ce que dans le phénomène de
sexualisation on a dit aux femmes qu'il
fallait supprimer ces poils donc c'est
pas de la biologie c'est purement la
construction sociale il faut questionner
ça et si elle ne sexualise pas justement
ce corps des hommes c'est parce qu'on
les autorise en fait les hommes à avoir
un corps les femmes n'ont pas le droit
de faire corps aussi bien dans l'espace
public que dans la société de manière
générale on efface les corps des femmes
sauf quand ils sont mises en scène donc
par exemple dans la publicité où là on
va accepter parce que ces décors
esthétisé et qui sont passés derrière le
regard des hommes
si on choisit d'être maîtresse de nos
propres records de le posséder
véritablement est en fait d'en être
actrice
là tout d'un coup il ya une sanction
c'est ça la véritable liberté c'est de
choisir de porter aussi bien un short
qu'un voile de faire absolument ce qu'on
veut sauf que quand il prend cette
liberté là on nous renvoie
systématiquement cette sanction
patriarcale
non on n'a pas le droit de castres on
veut de son corps et le corps des femmes
ne nous appartient pas il appartient aux
lois il appartient à l'état
il appartient aux ânes il appartient
même à la république sur tout mais on en
reparlera juste après sagna cacak oui il
ya plein de choses à dire que
effectivement que tout le monde n'ait
pas été hors sexuelle je suis
entièrement d'accord avec amy mais il
n'empêche qu'il ya aussi des otero
sexuelle et il faut apprendre
là aussi je suis d'accord il faut
éduquer sur tous les petits garçons les
les jeunes hommes
il faut les éduquer à contrôler leurs
désirs mais il faut pas les éduquer à ne
pas avoir de désir ça serait injuste il
les épreuves beaucoup les éprouve ses
désirs on peut rester hétérosexuels et
on peut être un homme hétérosexuel
respectueux des femmes
je suis d'accord qu'il faut lutter
contre contre la société patriarcale ya
encore beaucoup à faire et c'est
peut-être normal qu'il y ait des excès
en ce moment mais faut surtout pas
culpabiliser les jeunes hommes des
désirs qu'ils éprouvent il faut
apprendre à les leur apprendre à les
contrôler et à vous avant tout en les
femmes des sujets mais le problème c'est
que si on les culpabilise trop d désire
qu'ils éprouvent il va y avoir un retour
de bâton est une très grande violence
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas vous avez
raison sur tout ce qu'est ce qui est
culturel il ya beaucoup de choses à
changer
mais je ne pense pas qu'il faille nier
le fait que dans dans une relation
hétérosexuelle
la rencontre se fait à l'intérieur du
corps de la femme ça nous rend non pas
plus faible mais plus vulnérables et ça
c'est très important de l'expliquer et
aux filles et aux garçons les filles ont
envie de plaire historiquement plus que
les garçons alors ce que j'observe quand
même dans cette cette génération
millénium qui a été élevé vous disiez
camille que la seule la seule source
d'éducation c'est la pornographie
peut-être qu'on peut ajouter que c'est
la première et ça aussi c'est terrible
c'est à dire que ma génération
d'abord on a on a eu nos premiers nos
premières expériences sexuelles et
éventuellement après on a eu accès on a
pu voir des images pornographiques
aujourd'hui la majorité des jeunes
commence par la pornographie
ça c'est vrai que c'est terrible mais
mais mais donc est ce que j'observe et
je vous interromps mais je voudrais
savoir pourquoi c'est terrible le fait
qu'avant de jouer au football on regarde
des matchs de football
c'est pas horrible en soi sans pêche pas
que jouer au football
pourquoi est-ce que tout à coup ci on a
vu des gens faire l'amour avant ce
thread ça nous en l'air notre vie
sexuelle parce que les matchs de foot
c'est du foot
la pornographie c'est pas de la
sexualité c'est la mise en scène est vu
par les hommes de la sexualité c'est
très spectaculaire c'est à dire qu'il
faut que tout se voit dans la dans la
pornographie iab il ya aussi beaucoup de
violence il ya beaucoup de domination il
ya une confusion entre entre les il peut
y avoir à la presse humaine spécialistes
mais il peut y avoir une confusion entre
des actes qui peuvent être un peu
violent mais mais qui ne le sont pas
fondamentalement est une vraie violence
exprimée dans les films sexuelle donc
donc là dessus c'est terrible oui parce
que c'est pas c'est pas la vérité c'est
pas et puis la sexualité ça va être un
espace libre serre que chacun doit avoir
la cites la sienne si on commence à leur
mettre des images dans la tête et des
images qui ne reflète pas la réalité est
qu'ils sont qui sont sont souvent
humiliantes pour pour l'oeuvre pour les
femmes c'est pas une bonne chose c'est
parce je vais dire que ça cesse et c'est
très varié et la pornographie ya pas que
le porno qu'on voit sur canal plus il ya
de la pornographie homosexuelle il ya de
la pornographie dans tous les genres et
il doit ya voir même de la pornographie
ou les femmes dominent les hommes j'en
suis à peu près sûr
juste un mot sur la pornographie parce
que je vous voyais pas être d'accord
peggy sastre
c'est si terrible que ça pour les pour
les jeunes de de regarder de la
pornographie à votre avis et c'est comme
tous j'ai envie de jouer envie de
demander sur quel sur quelles données
vous vous fondez pour pour dire ça parce
que comment il ya quand même des gars
comme des études qui sont en fait dans
le dans le monde entier et notamment aux
états unis parce que c'est là qu'on a
c'est là quand il ya une tradition une
tradition statistique est beaucoup plus
solide qu'en france et en fait ce qu'on
voit c'est que effectivement la
consommation de porno augmente et
notamment ceux les jeunes ça c'est
indéniable mais en fait ces pratiques ne
bouge quasiment quelques aliments pas et
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
c'est même là c'est même l'inversé les
jeunes générations en faites pas les
très très jeunes justement les millénium
de ce que ceux qui ont aujourd'hui entre
25 et 35 ans arrive à des à des niveaux
de communiants de en fait de rapport de
vrais rapports sexuels qui n'ont jamais
été aussi bas depuis un siècle d'envoi
la dent depuis qu'on a une amplitude
statistiques et ça ça permet voilà cette
fois ça permet de relativiser beaucoup
se joue beaucoup de panique morale comme
on la voit la ccc comme pour le coup
c'est comme le sujet le sujet actuel sur
la les tenues les détenus des filles et
des jeunes filles cc voilà c'est un
marronnier qui revient qui revient à qui
revient à intervalles réguliers à la la
le porno le port nous détruit la
jeunesse mais en fait non la jeunesse
résisté très très
et très résiliente et n'est pas comme on
irait comme un lien pour conclure voilà
il ya vraiment un décalage entre les
données qui permettent d'affirmer ce
qu'on affirme de manière très très
péremptoire et voilà c'était de panique
morale ça doit faire avec voulait
ajouter quelque chose je voudrais vous
réponds peggy c'est que moi j'ai mon
expérience de 15 ans dans cyclos des
filles et de dizaines de lettres et puis
de mails de filles qui se demandent si
elles doivent accepter la sodomie ou la
fellation elle n'en n'ont pas du tout
envie mais elle pense que c'est être
cool parce qu'elles ont des copains
qu'ont vu ça dans des films elles les
ont vus aussi est ce qu'on appelle la
zone grise toutes ces filles qui font
des choses ça s'appelle pas
officiellement des viols parce qu'il
n'ya pas de plainte parce qu'elles
savent même pas que qu'elles ont le
droit de dire non et il ya quand même
une espèce de de votre d'habituation à
des pratiques qu'on n'a pas envie
forcément de faire quand on a quand on a
15 ou 17 ans et là dessus je pense qu'on
n'a pas beaucoup de données alors après
je vous dis pas que j'ai mon expérience
mais de 15 ans quand même de beaucoup
beaucoup de lectrices et moi j'ai été
très frappée et très choqué par ça nadia
langue joue dit merci oui enfin sans
même devoir attendre de pouvoir
consulter des des sondages ou des
données je pense que on est quand même
tous d'accord pour dire qu'aujourd'hui
la pornographie sexualisé jeune fille
est dans le même temps infantilise
les femmes on vit dans une société où
dans l'imaginaire collectif
plus on est jeune et plus on est belle
et ça c'est une conséquence quand même
directe de ces images pornographiques ou
des jeunes filles sont mises en scène
donc c'est aussi une réalité vous disiez
madame peggy sastre et que au contraire
tout laisse à penser que les femmes et
les hommes ont des rapports qui ne tombe
pas en tout cas vers des rapports
orthographique comme les conçoit avec la
violence et de la domination
vous disiez aussi parce que j'ai lu
votre article et samassa m'a interpellé
que les violences par exemple sexuelle
diminuer fortement dans l'espace public
alors qu'on a un sondage qui dit
totalement le contraire et là on a des
chiffres que 80% des femmes en france
disent avoir déjà subi une forme
d'agression ou d'atteintes sexuelles
aussi bien dans la rue que dans les
transports en commun donc là on a des
données scientifiques qui viennent
justement pas contredire votre vision
empirique de la situation pardon mais
peu pour préciser quand on demande aux
femmes c'est elles ont déjà subi leur
soit une agression sexuelle soit un viol
ou harcèlement dans les transports en
commun et que vous en avez 80% qui
répondent oui c'était pas l'année
dernière 1 c'est 80 % ou 10 18
ça n'aurait parié 10 soit au cours de
leur vie donc voilà sur les douze
derniers mois en 2018
ah c'était sur les douze villes qui a
travaillé au cours des 12 derniers mois
voilà c'est un sondage de l'ifop
voilà malheureusement il n'y a pas
d'autres faudrait peut-être solliciter
un autre à notre sondage c'est quand
même plus intéressant de soumettre on va
dire de consulter les femmes sur les
agressions sexuelles les atteintes
sexuelles ou de harcèlement qu'elle
subisse dans les transports que de
savoir ce qu'elle pense que la société
française tente d'un croc top par
exemple ou d'une mini-jupe etc voilà
alors justement venons sens puisque vous
l'avez soulevée dès le départ à cette
sexualisation de ce que vous appelez
camille les petites filles ou les
enfants
à savoir on est dans une société
extrêmement soucier sexualisé et cela
depuis plusieurs décennies déjà que ce
soit les médias la télévision le cinéma
les clips la publicité les journaux les
magazines féminins
tout ça est très très très sexualisée
beaucoup plus que ça ne l'était dans les
années 60 ou ou a fortiori avant les
années 60 le fait que vous ne soyez
contre la sexualisation des petites
filles fait qu'à la fin vous êtes contre
les crampes top au collège j'imagine
caby non non absolument pas je suis pour
la liberté à tout âge de porter les
habits qu'on veut pour moi le souci
c'est parce qu'on porte c'est le regard
qui est porté dessus et c'est là où pour
moi il ya une énorme audience c'est
qu'on ne devrait pas autoriser d'avoir
un regard pédocriminels sur des corps
d'enfants
personnellement j'ai toujours vécu à
paris et j'ai commencé à subir le
harcèlement de lui quand j'avais 10 ans
et j'en subis en fait de moins en moins
et j'en ai parlé avec pas mal de
personnes autour de moi donc des femmes
des personnes perçues comme femmes des
personnes ordinaires qui m'expliquait le
même vécu en fait au fur et à mesure
qu'on grandit au fur et à mesure qu'on
fait + mathieu et - fm1 subit moins ce
versement dû en subit moins ces
agressions parce que tout simplement il
ya cette culture de la docilité de la
douceur de l'enfance qui s'est installée
petit à petit aussi dans les médias
français
on l'a vu avec matzneff il a vu avec
polanski
il ya des excuses qui sont donnés aux
pédocriminels en permanence et donc
c'est ça en fait le coeur du problème de
cette polémique c'est au-delà du corps
des femmes dont on est en train de
parler c'est le corps des enfants qui
est au coeur de ce sujet là et c'est la
protection qu'on fait de ce corps des
enfants
donc on parlait tout à l'heure des ducs
et les hommes de manière générale il
faut aussi éduquer les adultes c'est pas
parce qu'on est adulte on a raison c'est
pas parce que ça fait 40 ans qu'on
exerce en tant que cpe qu'on a raison et
que la manière
on a de voir l'éducation elle est bonne
il faut une véritable formation de tous
les encadrants professionnelle par
rapport à ces sujets là c'est pas normal
qu'en 2020 il ya encore des cpe des
surveillants des professeurs qui se
permettent de porter un regard
libidineux sur des enfants
c'est pas normal qu on est à une grande
hurd écoute sur une télévision un homme
de 70 ans dont je ne citerai même pas le
late mérite pas cette publicité qui nous
disent que quand ils voient les ados
dans la rue en croupe top ça l'excité ce
n'est pas un discours normal ce n'est
pas un discours en temps d'hab c'est un
discours qui est condamnable et donc
pour moi de soucis ses pattes les en
point mais tu décroches top
le souci c'est pas quand même être plus
de soutiens gorge le souci c'est qu'on
autorise ces regards là qui sont
véritablement criminels qui sont
pédocriminels chaque belge suis tout à
fait d'accord avec le regard je suis
mais le problème c est ce que à 10 ans
on peut mettre un crop top je reviens
quand même au fait que certaines tenues
c'est pas le regard qui les rend
provocant il ya eu le procès qui a les
deux si vous voulez ya quand même des
tennis ici je me mets en string et que
je sors dans la rue bon non j'ai pas
j'ai pas large qu'il faut mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est quand même une
tenue qui est considéré comme sexuelle
et ça on pourra pas le changer la nudité
c'est c'est c'est la sexualité est donc
le après qu'il faille changer le regard
oui le problème c est ce que quand on a
11 ans on est on peut on peut comprendre
ça qu'on est à la fois objet et sujet
avant de vouloir plaire hans
objectivement on peut plaire en et en
liant l'humour en étant gentil en étant
intelligent mais par ailleurs on aime
plaire aux six ans objet tiezan en
mettant un collier en étant jolie en soi
font bien et est ce que on peut
comprendre avec dans la société de
consommation qui nous entoure avec
toutes ses stars qui se dénude
est ce qu'on peut est ce qu'on peut
comprendre que avant de vouloir plaire
en ce que j'ai 10 ans il faut se
respecter
on ne peut pas comprendre ça à 11 ou 12
ans donc il ya les deux affaires
parallèlement et vous pouvez pas
empêcher les hétérosexuels
peut-être qu'il ya effectivement plein
de gens qui ont des relations
homosexuelles et c'est très bien mais
vous pouvez pas empêcher les hétéros
d'être hétéro ça serait quand même
terrible mais vous pouvez pas non plus
dire que sous prétexte qu'on est sexy et
volontairement sexy on ne se respecte
pas parce que c'était l'argument qu'on
utilisait contre brigitte bardot dans
les années 50 je vous rappelle
alala elle ne se respecte pas ça n'est
pas ce que vous avez voulu dire non
évidemment que non mais vous savez
c'était c'est l'objet du film là qui a
été très très controversé le film
mignonne moi je pense que plein de
petites filles qui rêvent qui se
déhanchent devant devant kim kardashian
devant rien à elles peuvent pas
comprendre elles sont trop petit c'est
vraiment pas les mépriser que dire ça là
là on ne parle plus de femmes brigitte
bardot c'était une femme on parle
d'enfants
ll ne comprennent pas que les regards
qu'elle suscite d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que plein de d'enfants
qui ont été abusés pourquoi aussi elle
ne se sont pas plainte tout de suite
qu'elles ont attendu et après on le leur
reproche c'est qu'elle ne savait pas
mettre un nom sur ce qui était fait sur
le pape sur leur corps elles savaient
pas que c'était un regard sexuelle
qu'elle suscitait donc elle pouvait pas
s'en plaindre
et ça c'est terrible ce que j'ai aussi
qu'il faut quand même tout temps tout en
étant extrêmement sévère avec avec tout
ce qui est tout ce qui est pédophile et
pédocriminels et du tout ce flou
artistique qui est effectivement a
hérité de la société près de patriarcale
il faut par ailleurs prendre en compte
que quand on est un enfant on n'est pas
une femme et on n'a pas le même regard
sur son corps on n'a pas le même rapport
au corps et après oui tout à fait
vouloir plaire le truc c'est qu'en plus
vouloir plaire c'est ses sens et naturel
mais après ce objets tease et oui je
suis désolé avant de s'objecter il faut
se respecter il faut être construite et
quand on est fragile quand quand on est
dans une famille où on vous respecte pas
beaucoup pour plein de raisons
quand on sent pas bien c'est plus
dangereux dans tous les sens du terme de
ces objets tease et surtout à l'extrême
alors peggy sastre il nous reste 5
minutes je ne sais pas par quel bout
ce n'est pas par quel bout prendre tout
cela mais la voilà j'y pense que tout à
l'heure
claire c'est que ce que claire-lise est
sûre c'est culturel parce que la preuve
il y avait aussi des homosexuels jeu
peut-être que je vais le sol à décevoir
soit lui apprendre quelque chose mais il
ya aussi beaucoup d'études et de travaux
sur caen venir sur la biologie de mots
sécurité et pas seulement et pas
seulement chez les humains il ya
notamment des études très très
intéressante et pour le coup vraiment
très très drôle sur les macaques en fait
sur canton comme on ignore quand on
quand on joue sur les chaussures les
hormones nation sur les hormones et
femelles macaques
en gros quand on leur donne plus de
testostérone mal deviennent elles
deviennent plus agressifs ils et elles
deviennent aussi plus lesbiennes et et
c'est ce genre de chose pareille ce sont
des choses qui ne sont pas connus et
aussi je récuse totalement l'argument
qui est qui est souvent fait qu'elle
notamment et qui a été notamment été
fait ce soir un côté à la fois c'est
dangereux et c'est une justification
c'est pas du tout une justification
c'est pas parce que c'est naturel que
c'est bien vire les zorra mance naturel
les ouragans c'est pas bien elle est une
relance a fait des s'affaisse avait des
victimes essais etc et c'est dangereux
voilà et c'est la civilisation la
culture là la technique de commandes y
en a un soap aux gosses se protègent
contre les jours a grand mal à sexualise
la sexualité en fait c'est pareil quand
même y aller les balles des logiques de
la sécurité c'est pareil c'est pas parce
qu'on est les explique pas ce que les
expliquons et justifie parce que ça
c'est un gros truc voilà on peut lire un
manuel valls expliquer ce n'est pas si
ce n'est pas justifié ce que je fais
d'un mail est ce que je fais dans mes
travaux c'est pas du tout voilà c'est
pas du tout a justifié sa pas du tout
donner des excuses c'est pas du tout
dire que les filles qui ont été violées
sont responsables de ce qui leur arrive
et pas du tout mais c'est justement
comment lire c'est justement levée en
voile sur quelque chose qui n'est qui
n'est pas connu et qui est mal connue et
qui je pense et j'ai l'outrecuidance de
penser que si c'était mieux connu
les problèmes seraient mur est lié
johnny non je voulais juste rappeler
qu'effectivement on parle de d'enfants
en parle pas d'adultes donc les enfants
sont instable émotionnellement
si les parents exercent une autorité
justement parentale ce que la loi leur
reconnaît c'est que ça prouve que ces
enfants ne sont pas disposés ou alors
suffisamment armé pour faire des choix
réfléchis donc et puis et moi ce qui
m'inquiète beaucoup que ce soit ces
jeunes filles vous parlais tout à
l'heure de ces garçons et pourquoi pas
des garçons sexy c'est de voir cette
jeunesse finalement condamné à exister
par la séduction on n'existe que par la
séduction et c'est comme ça c'est ce que
disait mona chollet qu'on s'enferme
finalement dans une situation de de
subordination permanente d'être toujours
dans d'être sous l'emprise finalement de
cette tyrannie du look de la beauté de
plaire à tout prix etc
je pense que c'est pour ça que je le
disais au début le débat est vraiment
mal posée parce que la question de
l'hypersexualisation des jeunes filles
et même des jeunes garçons et même déjà
des jeunes garçons il ya énormément de
politique que ce soit aux états unis au
canada qui s'y intéresse parce qu' on
s'inquiète véritablement de l'impact sur
la sur le sur la santé psychique la
santé mentale la santé physique de cette
hyper sexualisation que je trouve qu on
occulte beaucoup dans ce débat à cause
de ce sondage qui forcément clive
dernière question mais il nous reste
très peu de temps pour la traiter mais
moi c'est ça qui m'inquiète c'est plutôt
quand on parle de la république et de
ski républicain
à tout bout de champ et contre il est
bon république ad pa bon républicain et
qu'on décrète tout à coup qu'il ya des
tenues républicaine
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire les tenues
républicaine qu'habib extrait non je
trouve que les nattes hier on parlait
très bien au début de l'émission en
expliquant que là on nous a expliqué il
n'y a pas très longtemps que le voile
les dépasse d'une tenue républicaine
maintenant c'est le propre top qui n'est
pas une tenue républicaine en fait je
pense que de manière générale être une
femme ou être perçu comme femme s'est
pas républicain encore une fois on est
en tant que femme personnes perçues
comme femme assignée à des espaces qui
sont privés on n'a pas à être visible de
quelconque manière
on nous infantilise encore une fois en
estimant mieux savoir que nous quel est
notre liberté
comment nous habiller comment vous
positionner dans l'espace public dans
les médias ex car et c'est ça le vrai
souci c'est que ce qu'on entend par
république ce que jean michel blanquer
entend par république aujourd'hui en
réalité pour moi c'est le patriarcat
il faut vraiment différencier et deux
années encore une fois des citoyennes de
seconde zone dans cette république où on
va nous acculer nous importe ce qu'on
fait on va estimer que d'autres manières
on n'est pas libre et qu'on n'a pas
l'intelligence suffisante pour savoir
nous mêmes ce qui est notre liberté et
c'est ça qui extraient mandat eh bien ce
sera le mot de la fin puisque l'émission
est terminée je vous remercie tout les 4
d'avoir participé je vous remercie de
nous avoir suivis et je vous donne
rendez-vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à